esta huelga ha sido programada para
martes jueves y sábado pero se prevé que
habrá complicaciones durante toda la
semana e incluso se habla de que esta
huelga podría extenderse todo el verano
los sindicatos de trabajadores están
reclamando un aumento laboral un aumento
salarial del 7% y además que no haya
despidos y es que el primero de julio
iniciará los encargados de estas
empresas una consulta para modernizar el
servicio de trenes en el país lo que
contemplaría despidos de al menos 1.800
personas
el primer ministro boris johnson ha
dicho hoy que esta huelga es
completamente injustificada
especialmente por la crisis que vive el
país la crisis económica después de la
pandemia del coi 19 y también por la
crisis del costo de vida que también
sacude fuertemente al reino unido